this is a Productivity killer that most
of us don't know about if you can't do
something as simple as waking up on time
today then how do you expect to go off
and tackle this big scary goals of yours
today
the best way to wake up not feeling
anxious of stress
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right to get there grab your coffee
and sip on today's message
don't hit the snooze button over to you
Mel Robbins also if you want to know
what Mel Roberts and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below everybody's
problem comes down to one pattern your
repeating that you can't see and if
you're somebody that's watching this and
you have no clue what you want I'm gonna
say that's total this is a Productivity
killer that most of us don't know about
it has to do with waking up now when you
think about being productive you got a
big day and you got a bunch of stuff you
need to get done most of us focus on
when when do I need to get up in order
to get everything done that's not what
you need to focus on the thing that
really impacts your productivity is how
how do you wake up and here's the deal
if you're somebody like I used to be
that hits the snooze button that kills
your productivity for at least four
hours let me explain you have to
understand this the snooze button
creates a mental state a state in your
brain that is called sleep inertia it's
so bad it actually has a name here's
what it is when you and I go to bed we
sleep in cycles we sleep in cycles of
like 90 to 110
minutes all night long and right before
you wake up the sleep cycles they stop
and your body goes into a wakeup mode
okay your brain is starting to slowly
wake up so that it can start the day
when your alarm goes off you're in
wakeup mode your brain is now ready to
do its best work however if the alarm
goes off and you hit the snooze button
guess what you've just done you've just
made your brain go back into a sleep
cycle your brain is now in a mode that
takes about ninety to a hundred and ten
minutes to complete
you just rebooted the system so when
your alarm goes off and you get up
fifteen minutes later you're now in
major trouble and the reason why you're
in trouble is because your brain is
still locked into a sleep cycle and this
is where sleep inertia comes in you know
how when you hit the snooze button you
wake up and you're like oh my gosh I did
not get enough sleep last night you feel
so groggy you kind of feel like this
mental hangover that is sleep inertia
here's the deal your brain the quartic
region of your brain which is
responsible for decision-making
attention alertness self-control that
sucker is still in a sleep cycle and now
that you're awake it's going to take the
chordal region almost four hours to
actually snap out of that sleep cycle
that's why you feel groggy it's because
the part of your brain that's
responsible for critical thinking and
being alert it's actually still asleep
if you don't already do this you've got
to train yourself to be the kind of
person that doesn't use the snooze alarm
because when you hit the snooze alarm
you're not only putting your brain in a
state of sleep inertia you are directly
impacting your productivity your
alertness and your brain processing for
the first four hours that you're awake
that's making life harder I'm all about
making life easier so tomorrow when the
alarm goes off I don't care how tired
you are I don't care how much you know
wanting in a bed I want you to remember
this
I want you to remember that you've got
to wake up and give your brain its best
shot to do its best work and the way
you're gonna do it five four three two
one turn off that alarm and get up seize
the day and go be productive
anybody who hits the snooze button every
morning you can bet is not super
successful if you are not ready when the
alarm goes off and you need to hit that
snooze button it's a big sign that you
are not ready for primetime and what
you're doing right now I can guarantee
you that garyvee Oprah Howard Schultz
whoever it is that you look up to they
do not hit the snooze button when they
wake up in the morning but hitting the
snooze button every morning doesn't just
ruin your brain it ruins your
self-esteem you set a goal last night to
wake up at a certain time this morning
and the very first thing that you do in
the morning is say BAM it's okay not to
hit my goal I'm not gonna hit my goal
today you are teaching yourself that you
are the kind of person who sets goals
and doesn't follow through
you are losing respect for yourself and
that is the worst possible start every
day that you can have for your life if
you can't do something as simple as
waking up on time today then how do you
expect to go off and tackle those big
scary goals of yours today this is why
it's really important that you are very
careful very clear about the goals that
you set for yourself and when you set
them you have to follow through you
cannot develop that identity of setting
goals and not doing it so as an example
I had a goal where I wanted to run every
day every day half an hour I was gonna
run and I was driving into Boston and it
was a long drive when we got in at like
2:00 in the morning and everybody's
tired we're ready to go to sleep I
hadn't done my run so what am I gonna do
I'm gonna go and do my run and it was a
crappy run you know I'm I'm on the spot
like kind of super tired it was not a
great run I did not burn a lot of
calories it was not probably fantastic
for for my system and the next day I was
even more tired than everybody else I
had less sleep I wasn't on my a-game the
next day and you might think well that's
a stupid thing to do just go to sleep
and everybody around me would have given
me the night off but it said don't worry
about it stew in the boardroom all the
way to here the Boston is crazy
go to
you don't have to do it don't worry
meanwhile that entire next day even
though I'm tired I'm I'm hi I'm petting
myself in the back I'm high-fiving
myself because I did it when it was
difficult when you set a goal for
yourself
and it's easy and you accomplish it it
doesn't feel like a win right if you set
a goal that you're gonna wake up and go
to the bathroom doesn't feel like a win
you gotta have to wake up and go to the
bathroom anyway when you said small
goals and hit them it may help you build
some momentum may help you feel like
you're checking stuff off the list but
you don't feel great about yourself
because you knew you could have done it
when you set a goal but then it's hard
to do right maybe not every day maybe
running is easy most days or just okay
most days but then some of this is gonna
be hard and that's the moment where you
build or lose respect for yourself if
you do the thing when it's hard
especially when it's hard and you still
do it when everybody would give you the
break when everybody would say don't
worry about it you don't have to do it
and you still do it that's when you
build insane self-esteem insane
self-respect insane self-confidence but
when you come up against any kind of
difficulty and you say I'm not gonna do
it today you know I'm tired I'm not
gonna do it today then you lose respect
for yourself and you're teaching
yourself that I'm the kind of person who
doesn't follow through I'm the kind of
person who sets goals and doesn't take
action I'm the kind of person who says
I'm gonna wake up tomorrow at 7 a.m. and
then I hit the snooze button eight times
and knock it up and that's how I start
my day every day don't let that be you
so I've got three things I want you to
think about today if this video has
meant anything to you I want you to
think about these three questions and
apply them into your life today and
tomorrow question number one what goal
do you have for yourself today
be very careful stop setting goals and
not following through pick one goal that
you need to accomplish before the end of
the day and then go out and accomplish
it step number two what time are you
gonna wake up tomorrow morning plan it
put it in your calendar set your alarm
and then get up at that time if you like
having an extra 20 minutes of snooze
time and you normally wake up at 7 then
set your alarm for 7:20 it's actually
better for you it's better for your
brain it's better for your body
set it for 7:20 and just get up
but I want you to decide right now write
it down I will wake up at this time
tomorrow and then do it and then number
three how are you gonna celebrate once
you hit your goal
when you finish your goal today whatever
you set for yourself and you do it how
are you going to celebrate when you wake
up tomorrow morning and you're used to
snoozing eighteen times but you just get
out of bed how are you going to
celebrate reward yourself celebrate give
yourself a pat on the back
a high-five do something to ingrain it
because when you celebrate when you feel
great about yourself you want to do it
again again and again and you're
building a positive momentum instead of
what you've been doing spiraling
downwards with negative momentum now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what time are you gonna wake up
tomorrow morning let me know make a
statement put it in the comments below
how do I start my day on the positive
side I often wake up anxious and
stressed well Craig thank you very much
for sending in your question I would
like to respond by first asking you a
question and my question is what do you
do before you go to sleep at night see
most people before they go to sleep at
night either checking the email on
social media watching violent TV show a
horror movie or reading a scary book all
of those things can make you have a very
restless sleep and chances are when you
wake up in the morning you could feel
very anxious and stressed so for example
if you go to sleep thinking about work
then your subconsciousness is going to
be involved throughout the night on
work-related issues and when you wake up
in the morning Challis how you can be
anxious and quite stress about it as
well so the best way to wake up not
feeling anxious of stress is to prepare
to go to bed and that's not something
that people do very often here are a few
simple things that you can do to prepare
to go to bed
you should stop working at least half an
hour before you go to sleep so turn off
your email don't go on social media just
completely shut off go take a shower
prepare to go to bed and when you get to
bed sit on the edge of your bed keep
your spine straight your head nicely
balanced on top of your neck take a slow
deep breath in and then slowly exhale
again and while you're doing this deep
breathing exercise focus entirely on
your spine and if you can't feel your
spine gently move your back from left to
right a little bit so you can feel your
spine focus on your spine as you breathe
in deeply and as you exhale slowly as
well and then just lay down on your back
and go to sleep and obviously this is
going to take practice you know what the
first day the second day but if you
consistently do this every night before
you go to sleep you start having really
good deep restful sleep and wake up not
feeling anxious or stressed if you want
more Mel Robbins check out the five
hacks and strategies to transform your
life video that I made the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and
are you there my life changed a couple
years ago when I discovered something
called the progress principle my night
routine is very simple leave no tasks
that I have to finish in the morning